[Music]
i think i need
bigger lungs
[Music]
how do you like my sand castle lucy it's
not very realistic
no one could ever live in a castle like
that
[Music]
ma'am i'm not going in the water yet
i just like being prepared
i even brought this appropriately themed
novelty cup full of fluids so i can
ensure i stay properly hydrated
[Laughter]
ah
h2o
sally have you seen my beach ball it
just left for hawaii
[Music]
snoopy if you're going surfing i don't
want you going out too far and no riding
the big waves only the small ones surf's
up
and no curving the a-frames or hanging
ten and no hot-dogging
if you'll pardon the expression
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
looking good snoopy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't bear to look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can i look now i wouldn't charlie brown
snoopy's about to wipe out
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
snoopy over here you can swim back if
you want you can probably walk back what
a goof ball
[Music]